- [Marques] What's your name?
- [Siri] I'm Siri, pleased to meet you.
- [Google] My nickname
is the Google Assistant.
- [Bixby] The name is Bixby.
- [Alexa] I'm Alexa.
(bright upbeat music)
- I've talked and made jokes in the past
mostly along the lines of
Google Assistant is clearly
the best virtual assistant
and then Bixby, Siri
and Alexa are various
levels of far behind.
But last time I did this
type of test was 2017
so I figured we should
revisit this a little bit,
retest things and figure out
if Google Assistant still actually is
the best virtual assistant
on a smartphone right now.
Also shout out to Clippy, the
original virtual assistant
whose ugly Christmas sweater for Microsoft
is actually what inspired
this one, the MKBHD 8-bit Drip
which you can get wall supplies last.
They're very limited
but they're at shop.mkbd.com, link below.
But I decided to start
with the simple questions.
You know The three things
that you ask from an assistant
the most often I think are
the weather, timers and facts.
So they all do fine with
the weather question,
probably the number one
query for me anyway.
And then for the most part,
they were also the same pretty quick
with just asking standard facts,
although for some reason they did disagree
on the height of one person.
But then for timers, for
timers, for one weird reason
Siri cannot do multiple
timers at the same time
on the iPhone.
If you have a timer running
and ask for a second timer,
it asks you every time
if you want to replace
the first timer.
Pretty basic stuff
that I'm not sure why
Apple hasn't fixed yet.
Especially because you
can set multiple timers
at the same time with
Siri on a HomePod mini.
But anyway, I don't wanna make you watch
a whole bunch of back to back
to back questions and answers
because I admit it was kinda
boring when I was doing
all of that testing but I'm
going to share some examples
of what I found with you and
then some of the highlights
of the testing and the way
it answers these questions
when you interact with them.
So here we go.
So with all the latest software
updates on every assistant,
all being asked the exact same questions,
asked to do the exact same
tasks with the same phrasing
and on the same WiFi connections,
most often the fastest one to answer
was Google Assistant or Siri.
But, but Siri and Bixby, in my experience,
did have the most
instances of like hanging
and pausing and not really
answering a question.
Kinda like acting like they
had a poor internet connection
even though they didn't.
Not sure why they did that.
A restart of the phone
helped with the Bixby one.
Siri just kinda does it randomly,
not sure why but that's a real fact.
But then with straight up fact questions,
there is no runaway winner
which I think is a good thing actually.
So if you ask something
that's easily Googleable
or on Wikipedia, something
like how tall is the Taj Mahal?
They can all get it.
Or if you ask, what do whales eat?
They all had some type of answer for me
that was basically the same.
Siri I found relies the
most heavily on Wikipedia
as a source for almost all of its answers.
And then when it does have
to go outside of that,
it just kinda throws up a web search link
often with Wikipedia at the top,
says, "Look what I Googled for you."
Now Google Assistant is
the most likely to give you
a nice visual and
slightly more information
than you asked for.
Bixby is powered by Google
so I would say it's
the most likely to read
what Google assistant reads word for word.
And then Alexa is the
most likely to throw in
some extra information about
your latest Amazon order
or something random.
So facts, they can all do, great.
Then there is what I'd call
the device control category
because these are assistants
that are on your smartphones,
they're smart speakers as
well but on your phone,
you'd like to be able to
help you out with things
while you can't use your hands.
And for this, there was a
runaway winner, actually two
and that would be Google
Assistant and Bixby.
So with the most basic, basic stuff,
they're pretty much all fine.
They can all change their
screen brightness, for example,
except Alexa.
But they can also all open the camera
or pretty much any app on your
phone with a voice command.
That's easy.
Setting an alarm is light work.
If you ask it actually
to open the app store,
they all open their respective app stores
and actually Bixby opens
the Samsung Galaxy Store
which is kinda cheeky.
But when it starts to get more complex,
Google and Bixby start to
walk away from the others.
So if I ask it to take a selfie,
Siri and Alexa will just open the camera
but Bixby and Google
actually open the camera,
switch to the selfie camera
and start a self-timer and
actually take a selfie.
If I wanna say play
"Squid game" on Netflix,
both Google and Bixby will
actually open the Netflix app,
find the first episode of
"Squid Game" I haven't seen yet
or wherever I left off
and start playing it.
Siri just opens the app and Alexa is lost.
If I say start a voice recording
or a voice memo for Siri,
again, Google and Bixby
open the voice recording app
and actually start that recording.
Siri again just opens the app.
And again, Alexa is lost.
These voice commands when they
work are legitimately faster
than I would've been able to do it by hand
for the most part.
And there's a bunch of
other device specific stuff
that Samsung has programmed
into Bixby where it can reach
into apps and perform
specific commands within them.
So if there are apps who use a lot,
this can potentially
save you a lot of time.
Bixby was also great at
this last time I did it
and also Alexa is unsurprisingly
the worst at device control
because they aren't
making their own phone.
These aren't Amazon phones.
So the vertical
integration's great with Siri
and Google Assistant and
Bixby, not with Alexa,
not a shocker there.
What might be a little
bit of a surprise though
is conversationalism.
Who is the coach of the Phoenix Sons?
Huh, how tall is he?
(soft upbeat music)
Did he play in the NBA?
What team did he play for?
(soft upbeat music)
So you can see, Siri tapped out
after about four questions
in a row about the same thing
but Google Assistant
is incredible at this.
It's really, really good
at remembering the context
and the subject of a natural conversation
and carrying that on through
a bunch of questions in a row.
Where is the Taj Mahal?
(soft upbeat music)
Okay, how tall is it?
How many meters is that?
(soft upbeat music)
What is it made of?
See, again, Google remembers
what we're talking about.
When is the Weeknd's birthday?
(soft upbeat music)
What's their latest album?
What's his real name?
(soft upbeat music)
So basically, if you're asking
a bunch of questions in a row
or if you have one subject that you want
to basically research
through the voice assistant
or get a bunch of answers on,
your best bet is definitely
Google Assistant.
And then one more interesting
thing from the crew
is that I ask just as
far as getting pictures.
When you ask for pictures of something
like dogs for example,
they can all search the web
except Bixby didn't.
And Alexa, which is looking
for an Amazon Photos app
for some reason.
But when you say, show
me my pictures of dogs,
Google actually opens and
searches in my own Photos album
for my own pictures of dogs.
So I did a bunch of
other testing like this
with a bunch of other different questions,
different styles of questions,
follow up questions and things like that
and I've come to a
pretty solid conclusion.
So if you're wondering
which one is the best;
"Marques, you did all these tests,
"which one came out as number one?"
Only one thing became exceptionally clear
through all this testing
which is that Alexa
is clearly the worst, is
clearly far behind the others
as a smart assistant on a phone.
I mean, unless maybe you're already deep
in the Amazon Alexa ecosystem
with everything working
perfectly in your smart home.
Matter of fact, this really
is an ecosystem question
almost as much as it is a skills question
for the assistants.
Because if you are super all in
on one of these smart home ecosystems,
that actually could answer
the question for you.
Of course, if you're all in with HomeKit,
then Siri and then iPhone
is your only option
to view your cameras and
see your doorbell ringing
and turn on your lights
and all that stuff.
But if you are doing the
same with Google Home
and Google Assistant, then you're there.
Now the next Gen Matter
standard may change all of this.
It may actually make
this section irrelevant,
maybe leave the thumbs up
on this video or comment
if you're interested in a
video about that specifically.
But for now, with these different
silos of home ecosystems,
that's pretty important.
But I'll still say from
my most common experiences
and queries and the things
that are most useful;
across every single phone,
iPhones or Android phones,
the most useful assistant
is still Google Assistant.
And that's multiplied if
you also happen to have
a pixel phone because then
you also get call screening
and Hold for Me and all
those extra pixel features.
But in general, Google Assistant
is most likely to be fast.
It's most likely to give a
good well sourced answer.
It's most likely to be conversational
and remember context longer.
And it has a bunch of third party plugs,
tons of app support.
And I also happen to
have built my smart home
in the Google Home world so it's great.
Now for the second best, I'm
very tempted to say Bixby.
Of course though, this is only relevant
if you have a Samsung phone.
And also, it is basically
saying all the same
first query responses
that Google assistant was
minus the ability to
talk to a smart speaker
since Samsung would probably
like us to forget about that.
But I am gonna have to put
Siri in second place here.
It's fine, it's okay
it's all right, it's fine, it's not great
but it is the most well
plugged into Apple's ecosystem.
So of course, if you're
doing HomeKit stuff,
it's gonna work well there.
It does support a smart speaker
which can do multiple timers
if you're not doing stuff
all the time on your phone.
And it does support routines
which is like stacking a
bunch of different commands
into one action if you're
willing to dig through
the very convoluted Siri
shortcuts interface.
So that puts Bixby in third
place and Alexa is just bad,
it's just bad on a phone.
Like there was a phone a couple years ago,
an HTC phone where it was built in
so there was Google Assistant
and Alexa side by side
on the same phone and it
worked kinda well back then
but that was years ago and
Alexa is just dead last
on a phone right now and Amazon knows it.
Amazon is falling behind with Alexa
and if you're just
starting to use assistants
or put together a smart
home or this type of stuff,
I would say avoid things that
are Alexa exclusive right now.
But until then, let me know if you agree
that Google Assistant still
seems pretty far out in front
or maybe there are some
specific features that you find
the most useful in a virtual assistant.
Let me know in the comments.
Either way, channel sponsor Dbrand,
also would like you to know
that they are relaunching
the Damascus skin.
They're bringing it back
due to popular demand.
It's got all this like crazy
reflective holographic chaos.
You can kinda skin whatever
device you want too
so you can make it work and you
get a free Triple Black skin
with your order, which is
sick, I'll link it below.
Thanks for watching and I'll
catch you guys in the next one.
Peace.
(bright upbeat music)